non-minimalists
we are in the summer season
and this is a time that many people take
a vacation
i'm just curious if you guys think that
if somebody is living a life that is
aligned with their values
if they should feel like they
need a vacation from their life
i'd be really curious to hear your
answer to this question and to also hear
you each expand a little bit um
expand on a little bit about your
feelings towards how you viewed vacation
when you were working in the corporate
world and how you
view vacation now as minimalist so
ashley what's fascinating about this is
i think there are sort of two types of
vacations here one is a vacation where
you're trying to get away from something
the other is a vacation where it's
almost a pause or a a change in the
rhythm
now andrew i was thinking about this on
your new album you have a song on there
called shorthand which is sort of a
vacation in the middle of the album
totally in a way so can we talk about
that it's almost like this needed pause
yeah no that's a good way to describe it
um
each of my records uh this is the fourth
one now each one right somewhere in the
middle either track five or six
has a song that's a little bit of
an outlier relative to the rest of the
songs um
and the first time i did that it was
just sort of by accident you know i made
a song that was two and a half minutes
long didn't really it didn't really fit
the typical structure of a song
lyrically or there wasn't really a
chorus and then my second record there
happened to be another song that was
similar and then so then that kind of
became a thing that i like to do and um
there's something nice i mean this
actually on the fourth record it's a
full-on instrumental there's no vocal at
all and that was something i always
wanted to do
i like the idea of being able to pause
and be somebody else for a minute on my
recordings or even in live performance
it's it's kind of nice
to take a break from
uh you know not for any
not because i don't like who i am or
being who i am or whatever i don't know
there's just something kind of
refreshing to me to like somewhere in
the middle just sort of like a palette
cleanser you know uh sonic
uh your ear cleanser uh for the for the
listener to be able to kind of reset and
then
start the back side of the record and
that's that's very intentional yeah and
now you're sort of you're on tour you're
doing these different cities but you're
also i saw you're sort of treating it
like a vacation esque thing right
it's i mean that's more of a mindset
than anything else because you can look
at it as a slog
or it's a oh my god i can't believe i
get to do this
yeah that's that's totally true i that's
a that's a decision decision i have to
make every day is like last night we
were coming in to los angeles it's been
we had a long day we my manager chris
and i we we played golf all day in
nashville which was so fun but so
exhausting and then went straight to the
airport and flew here and i'm like
so tired from the night before you know
we played a late show the night before
and and i was starting to get kind of
crabby like
i'm gonna get no sleep tonight and i
gotta run around town and then i gotta
play the show my voice is tired and i
got all these press and people coming to
the show and i wanna put on a good show
and and then i i thankfully was able to
just sort of stop and be like just chill
out man like everything's going great
everything's going to be great um you're
so lucky to be able to do this in the
first place
this is like this has been the easiest
tour by design it's it's uh rather than
taking on a big huge production with us
we just we're just doing an acoustic
tour i have one instrument on my back um
everything has been so easy and and uh i
got to bring my wife with us to new york
city last weekend we had
an amazing time and
yeah so it's definitely a choice to like
shift your mindset like to your point um
and just be grateful
yeah i feel that way a lot on our tours
it's like yeah same exact thing the
worst is like you got to show
you know uh at night you don't get back
to the hotel till 10 i'm like an
extrovert so like i got all this energy
yeah after a show so i don't go to bed
till midnight and then you got a flight
at like 6 30 a.m and it's like oh wow
but yeah it is perspective i have to
stop sometimes look in the mirror and be
like dude you've got good problems these
are not bad problems to have but you
know to answer um ashley's question
head-on
you know there's no right or wrong
answer to this
because what ashley is saying is like
hey if you're living with your values
then you're getting up every day and
every day is a gift and every day is a
vacation so do you need a vacation away
from your vacation
and that might be for some people but
still you know vacations are it is an
opportunity to pause it doesn't mean you
don't like your life it's maybe
something you can do to ex to get out
there and explore something new
or maybe you are just working and you're
tired of working i mean you know work is
work yeah even though you know all three
of us here at this table love what we do
there's work that has to be done that we
wish we didn't have to do you know i
hate paying taxes but guess what we have
to do that yeah and you might need a
break from that sometimes it's just
gonna feel you know
there's nothing wrong about that drew i
think that that one thing i think about
is with music even with a song like
the the music is music because of the
pauses between the notes or between the
lyrics or between the verses like
otherwise it's just noise
and so even if you live a life that you
feel is meaningful and enjoyable all the
time
if there isn't a rhythm to that
you can get burnt out yeah just like if
you're playing the same note over and
over there's this old like buddhist
parable about
the the guy who found
actually i think it's like a sufi
parable but the the guy who found the
perfect note he's just playing in the
town square over and over and over
people coming why don't you play the
songs you used to play is like well no i
found the perfect note
so i'm just strumming the same note over
and over and over
you kind of need a vacation from that
right yeah so if the vacation is running
towards something not running away from
something
that's when i find it to be useful yeah
for sure that made me think about how
with podcasts like we'll listen to it on
1.5 or sometimes 2.0 if you're josh you
can't do that with an album oh yeah you
can't you can't put it on 1.5 and just
get through the album and experience it
i really want to give you ranger bells
out but i only have 10 minutes right
exactly i'm going to put it on 2.0 and
listen to it real quick
yikes yeah well ashley let's send you a
couple tickets to our san francisco tour
stop the love people use things towards
coming to san francisco 20 cities total
across the u.s and canada we'll be there
in either january or february up in san
francisco we're going to be all over the
place um you could find a city nearest
you the minimalists.com tour if you're
listening to this or if you're ashley
we're going to go ahead and send you a
couple tickets to that event did you
enjoy this video if so you can listen to
full episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
percent advertisement free